I am going to start with a high low
question for both of you can you each
give me a high from shooting the way of
water a day that went really well felt
really good to you but then also can you
give me a low or super challenging day
and tell me how you overcame that
challenge
but he's first
I don't have like a a high would
Maybe
it was also good so it's hard to think
of just a hand just a low because I feel
like you also have so many up ups and
downs and I think as an actor my acting
coach always says like never say like
that you like weaknesses because it's
something it's a craft and it's always
evolving and I think watching me play
said I are seeing it now that I'm 19 and
I was 13 14 15 doing that role I'm like
wow I think I'm such a better actor now
but in reality I wouldn't change
anything that I did as saidia so when
you're asking like high or low I know
I'm just supposed to answer it straight
on it's hard for me to choose a high or
low because I think acting is such an
evolving craft that's a beautiful way to
look at it oh thank you now Dare I ask
for a hike
um hi um being Huff naked on a mountain
um with uh Cliff Cutters in Hawaii uh
low uh my first evidence story having to
film a scene on set because to me it
didn't really go very well but um
amazing stuff I think it ended up being
phenomenal though we didn't go better we
then got better but in when it ended up
in the movie is what I'm saying my first
day filming you know the two there's
like a massive door in between the two
stages and which we have like 30
cameramen sometimes in all 30 cameraman
will come into this stage to film
like a Top Gun slow-mo like yeah that's
why it was bad wait now I want the story
the story about Cliff Curtis in Hawaii
yeah oh um
we did like we did like um like a
training yeah holiday so we went
training in Hawaii while filming and so
because I met kaina I didn't do like
Forest training I just did water stuff
and that's it Jamie did some water stuff
because you know they come the Sully's
come to the mecca Ina Clan and then he
was in the forest oh yeah and then yes
then with Cliff Curtis so like me and
Cliff aren't we doing anything he's
doing something with um Jim's doing
something worries today is Dad and Jim
just sort of goes oh Cliff teach Jamie
the hacker and um cliff goes okay we
should do this with a view and I need to
do it and then we both go on a journey
it's got a beautiful I love it I wish
that was included in the b-roll or
something nice blue Blu-ray DVD someone
recorded that oh okay
I just lied to you I'm sorry we'll stop
that
um Bailey specifically for you now I
know you were really excited when you
found out Kate Winslet was gonna be your
mom yeah gone through the experience of
working with her what's something about
her as a scene partner that you really
appreciated and now maybe even want to
do for another scene partner of yours in
the future she's very Kate's very
protective when it comes to when there's
kids on set
um and then when there's also women on
set and I understand why and I think
just innately being around such strong
women on set even with Zoe and Sig I do
that to Trinity all the time now I'm so
protective even Jack like I feel like
anyone who's younger than me I want to
make sure that they feel safe and that
they like all the nerves should wash
away and I want them to feel protected
so that's something that she did that I
I adopted and I hope that anyone that I
do that to they also feel that Comfort
this is an important thing to have I
love it